whichever one of you guys comments first
in the comment section when you're
actually fourth oh my god the social
network all right so I've been waiting
for the social network be sure to be
exaggerated true story of the
trafficking of the digital drug known as
Facebook Jesse Eisenberg plays Mark
Zuckerberg the founder of Facebook who
then teams up with Timberlake who plays
the guy who jacked the Napster idea from
Seth Green from the Italian Job
no respect and then betrayals and suing
z' and scandals and all that fun
that happens when you mix business and
friends now the social network was not
only a good movie but it was really
interesting it's like hackers meets blow
hey addictive and everyone's doing it
drugs and Facebook and the movie shows
women how guys actually operate and here
it is guy meets girl girl and guy date
girl burns guy and then the guy becomes
crazy self-motivated and works his ass
off to make a name for himself online
and possibly even rub it in her face
yeah that's pretty much the size of it
and no that's not why I started doing
this but life does have its bonuses and
the movie is really well acted I mean
Mark Zuckerberg seems to be one of those
really logical arrogant types which they
pissed me off sometimes but the guy's a
billionaires so kings to him and
Timberlake he was really good in it but
the thing that freaks me out is the guy
who's gonna be the new Peter Parker's in
the movie and there's something about
him that really reminds me of Hayden
Christensen but he is a good actor so
there is that so I think everyone who's
watching this video right now should
watch the social network because it will
be relevant to you because if you are on
YouTube you are on Facebook and that's a
fact and the movie tells the story
of one of the largest social networking
sites of all time and the youngest
billionaire of all time so that's like a
twofer so I personally would say I would
buy this movie even on blu-ray although
I might be a little biased it being
about a guy who hits paydirt online I
mean honestly the whole time I'm just
watching the movie and I'm going how
could I do that how could I make that
work for me how'd he do that
then again he was wearing a Gap t-shirt
so it was back when that was in style
but if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more than click
right here to see more